right now one is 16 weeks pregnant  it still seems unbelievable on Monday  night's Dancing with the Stars Nick  Carter confirmed he and his wife Lauren  are expecting their first child together  but admitted there were struggles along  the way we've been trying to have a baby  for about a year now it's been rocky be  quite honest with you we were pregnant  before and we lost the baby and it was  really hard on Nick after performing  this heartfelt dance which earned a  perfect 30 out of 30 the singer got  emotional Nichkhun Shauna beautiful  vocals  I just want to do a good job for her  sorry I'm just so emotional but I'm just  I'm just overjoyed  the couple had one more surprise in  store we are going to reveal the sex of  your baby and you don't know right so  you're both gonna learn right here live  look straight boy